All right.
Uh,
so today we start a sequence which takes us through deconstruction.
and it's a sequence which has genuine coherence.
That is to say,
these are figures,
all of whom are attentive to each other's thought,
uh,
draw on each other,
and build from the materials that we're going to start covering,
uh,
toward,
a certain,
not end,
but toward a moment,
uh,
and which the materials seem to be undermined actually,
in deconstruction,
but in which they are still prominent.
And set the terms of debate,
the,
the relationship between,
uh,
the Russian formalists and the work of the linguistic linguistic Ferdinando.
So sewer,
which will be taking up on Thursday is a complex one.
I'm going to say certain things about it.
Uh,
and you may find yourselves discussing this relationship in section,
but I think much will come clear when we actually get into what's called
structuralism.
And you read the essay by Roman Jakobson called linguistics and poetics.
Jaco Epson having,
uh,
spent his,
the early part of his career as a card carrying member of Oprah's eyes,
the Russian formalists,
uh,
and then who,
owing to various forces that I'll be talking about immigrated first to Prague,
Czech and Slovakia,
where he joined a linguistic circle,
uh,
which it,
which in a variety of ways,
uh,
proved to be the origin of what's called structuralism.
And then of course,
he moved on to Paris where he knew Claude Levy Strauss and influenced him,
uh,
and ultimately to the United States.
But the essay linguistics and poetics,
which you'll be reading next week,
I think we'll give you perhaps a clearer sense of the way in which the Russian
formalists work and the work of so sewer,
the foundational work of,
so sir,
in the general course in linguistics,
um,
amalgamates,
uh,
in ways that,
are profoundly,
uh,
fruitful and influential for the subsequent course of structuralist and
deconstructionist thinking.
So today,
uh,
we begin thinking about the Russian formalists,
but I also do want to think them as kicking off a tradition which,
uh,
just in order to place them visa vi what you've been reading and hearing about
already.
Uh,
I one can say something like this about this tradition,
it differs markedly from it's opposed to hermeneutics in this one particular,
and it's one that is maybe initially counterintuitive,
but I actually I think is rather important once you began to think about it.
Hermeneutics is well more or less than by nature,
by nature,
by definition,
interested in meaning.
That is to say the arts of interpretation are used for the purpose of
discovering,
uncovering,
arriving at meaning,
and very frequently as is the case and got him.
Or this meaning is called the subject matter.
That is,
that is to say what in thinking about,
uh,
literature in terms of form and content,
let's say we'd call content.
So in any case,
hermeneutics is devoted to the discovery of meaning and it's basic and the art
that it's concerned with is the art of interpretation.
Well,
the Russian formalists differ very sharply in this regard because what they're
interested is precisely the way in which literariness as they call it,
the devices of literariness,
uh,
can be deployed so as to impede,
to interfere with,
to hinder our arrival at meaning.
If in other words,
hermeneutics is devoted to the possibility of,
of,
of communication,
of understanding the Russian formalists are interested in that special aspect of
verbal communication called literariness,
which actually interferes with these very processes of communication and
understanding the roughening of the surface,
uh,
celebrated Busche Klowski as a form of defamiliarization.
The roughening of the surface is what slows us down,
what gets in the way of our arriving at meaning and does so for a variety of
reasons that the formulas are engaged to attend to.
Now,
you may take note of the fact that what I'm saying,
uh,
isn't completely convincing perhaps to those who have been reading the new
critics and Wolfgang Eser and have noticed that they too are very interested in
the ways in which literariness does involve special techniques and devices that
slow us down.
In other words,
it replacing the shortest distance between two points that we experience in a
practical message literariness as the formalists call it a poetic language,
um,
as they also sometimes call it.
And as the new critics certainly call it slows us down.
It creates as a distance between two points rather than a straight line,
an arabesque.
In other words,
it makes us pause over what were reading.
It gets in the way of arriving to quickly at meaning if indeed one arrives at
meaning at all.
The formalists are concerned about,
however,
about the way in which literature is put together.
Uh,
those titles that I can bomb keeps talking about how Don Quixote was made,
how go goals overcoat was made,
uh,
reflect the preoccupation of the Russian formalists with how literature is put
together.
In other words,
whereas the new critics and Wolfgang Eser are interested in the roughening of
form.
They're interested in it for hermaneutic purposes.
It slows us down yet,
but this slowing down is a means of enriching what we finally grasp to be the
meaning of a text.
So they are still engaged in the hermeneutic enterprise in interpretation.
The formalists,
uh,
art,
really relatively indifferent to questions of meaning to questions of
interpretation.
They're interested in the interest of what they call science.
They're interested in structure,
they're interested,
in other words in the way a text is put together.
Uh,
and that is,
I think essentially the difference between what we've been talking about so far,
even though it has had a variety of outlooks,
uh,
and what we are talking about now temporarily as we advance through the
syllabus,
we're bracketing are suspending our interest in meaning and focusing instead on
how something is made.
Take for example,
Tony,
the tow truck.
Uh,
I mentioned,
uh,
well I can't remember what I mentioned.
It could have been in the audio.
You'll be hearing,
uh,
I mentioned that,
an interesting phenomenon in Tony,
the text of Tony,
uh,
is the tri partition of the t sound Tony,
tow truck.
And just after we read in the text,
Tony The tow truck,
we encounter a triadic or triple and counter with vehicles,
Nido speedy,
bumpy.
In other words,
there's a threeness which appears at a variety of levels in the text of tone of
the tow truck,
which exactly corresponds to the aphorism of Osi breek quoted by Eichenbaum and
your text repetition in verse is analogous to Tautology in folklore.
Now we have uncovered something about the form,
the structure of tone of the tow truck in saying this,
but we haven't discovered or uncovered a thing about the meaning of Tony the tow
truck.
Nothing follows from this really I think rather interesting observation that
there's a kind of pervasiveness of triadic city.
Uh,
nothing follows from this observation about the actual meaning of the text.
Now if you're clever enough,
maybe you could parlay it into a sense of the meaning of the text.
Who knows?
Maybe we'll try on some other occasion.
But for the moment,
I think you can see that in making remarks of this kind about a text one has
shifted the attention from meaning to structure and it's in that context that
most of the observations we encounter in Russian formalism need to be
understood.
Now the stress on taxonomy,
in other words,
the stress on the relationship among parts,
the understanding of the various parts of the literary texts as device of
literary texts as devices,
uh,
that is to say interrelated one with the others.
This emphasis on taxonomy is one of the ways in which the formalists and says
that what they're doing is scientific.
Nobody can possibly miss in reading.
I can bombs rhetorically rather bizarre essay.
Uh,
his obsession with struggle with the fight,
with doing battle.
I mean,
you,
your gone and say to yourself,
good heavens,
it's just talk about literature,
you know,
relax,
what,
it can't be that important,
you know,
but there's a,
but,
but for I involved,
there's obviously a lot at stake and I'll,
and I'll try to give you some social and historical reasons why this is the
case.
But in the meantime,
what he's struggling for is important to recognize too.
In the very first sentence of the essay,
you read the expression,
thus struggle for science,
an interesting formulation,
thus struggle for science.
Now,
obviously the struggle takes place against the backdrop of completely
undisciplined and an unsystematic thinking,
which I could bomb identifies as the typical thinking of the universities of the
academy.
Uh,
I mean it's a,
it's a pretty state of affairs in his view,
uh,
when the most rigorous thinking that's being done about literature as being done
in popular journals.
Uh,
and so that's part of the struggle undoubtedly.
But another part of the struggle,
uh,
is,
simply it to,
to reach some means to break through to some means of understanding the thing
that you're talking about.
You want to talk about it systematically,
but how can you talk about anything systematically if you don't know what it is,
you need to pin down an object of study,
a first principle from which other principals can emerge.
And part of the process is a to say,
hey,
it's not literature we're talking about who knows what literature is.
Nobody's really ever known what literature is.
What we're talking about is literariness.
That is to say certain devices that we can identify that perform a certain
function and maybe out of their identification of these devices to evolve a
theory,
a that's more widespread.
Now I use the word evolve deliberately in the backdrop,
in the background of that expression struggle for a science.
There are two key figures.
The first is obviously marks against the backdrop of um,
the first,
uh,
great socialist revolution,
which eventually resulted in the Bolshevik revolution of 1917 when the Russian
formalists movement was at its height,
uh,
against the backdrop of Marxists thought a pervading,
not just rush in life,
but beginning to pervade Russian government against this backdrop.
The idea of struggle as in class struggle is going to predominate and I can
bomb,
uh,
in this culture will be using such a word,
advisedly,
almost familiarly.
But at the same time,
it's very interesting that the kind of science he's thinking about is not just
any science.
You'll see this more and more clearly as you read through the text.
And as we talk about it,
it's Darwinian science.
And it's very interesting that Darwin,
that Darwin,
as much as Marx is all about struggle,
the struggle for survival,
the struggle for dominance.
And notice the important,
we'll come back to it,
the importance of the word dominant,
the dominant and the thinking of the Russian forum list,
the struggle for dominance among species in the habitat.
So in literature you have something like if you think in terms of literary
evolution as you retain Yanoff does,
uh,
in the essay,
that the passage on your sheet,
uh,
and uh,
if you think in those terms,
you think about literary history itself as a sequence of changes in which
devices,
aspects of literary text struggle for dominance within and over against other
devices.
And so it is,
uh,
a simultaneously in his very first sentence,
a Marxist and a Darwinian vocabulary that I can bomb is invoking,
and that's what partly accounts for the strenuousness of his rhetoric.
You know,
I mean,
there is the backdrop of class struggle,
which is understood as crucial.
There is the fermentation of Darwinian thought,
which at the same time is understood as as crucial a great deal is at stake.
And if those,
if those disorganized unsystematic academics,
um,
aren't attuned to the importance of these struggles,
right.
Class struggle,
the struggle for science science as the science of struggle if they aren't
attuned to these,
uh,
currents,
these contemporary occurrence.
That's just another way of showing how irrelevant and obsolete they are now on
literary,
on literary of,
I'm sorry,
uh,
the theory of the formal method,
I can bombs Essa that you've read for today was written in 1927.
In other words,
it was written directly in the aftermath of a bombshell published by the on
Trotsky called literature in Revolution in 1926.
Trotsky's literature in Revolution is a brilliant book,
uh,
and attack on many things,
a defensive,
certain other things,
but in particular and very painfully an attack on the formalists.
Trotsky argues that the preoccupation with form in and for itself is a kind of
aestheticism.
Something by the way,
which I can,
Bob denies during the course of his texts is a kind of s that a CISM turning its
back on history and turning its back precisely on class struggle.
Trotsky is not simple minded in his literary taste and he doesn't just sort of
spontaneously insist that everybody has to write socialist realism.
That doesn't by the way happen until 1934,
uh,
when it became a kind of,
pronouncement of necessity at the International Soviet writers conference on
that occasion.
But in the meantime,
it is a shot fired across the bow of those forms of aestheticism,
quote unquote,
which can be understood as self-involved,
self preoccupied and indifferent to history and class struggle.
It's 1927
things are changing.
It's been 10 years since the revolution.
Uh,
there is a kind of taking hold of society and government by increasingly
bureaucratized and strict forms of surveillance,
uh,
and uh,
and management of social matters,
whether and to what extent the Russian formalists and their allies,
the futurists among them Mayakovsky and others,
uh,
felt,
um,
uh,
kind of antagonism or growing threat from the government is not wholly clear to
me.
It is,
it is.
It's,
it's,
it's been disputed.
Uh,
and,
and one doesn't know for sure.
I mean,
there is still a tremendous amount of intellectual ferment and excitement in the
capitals of Russia.
This is not,
you know,
this is not a wasteland of thought by any means.
And the Russian formalists are an important part of what's going on.
Nevertheless,
uh,
Trotskyists book is a provocation.
It's a challenge.
Uh,
and I can bombs a essay that you read for today is in part to a degree that it
can't really come out and talk about,
doesn't want to come out and talk about it.
A response to Trotsky's book.
Now there were,
but obviously,
you know,
he's,
he,
he doesn't say,
he doesn't want to say anything about that.
There's one way in which he does talk about it.
And that is a marvelous exchange between the ethnographic critic vessel Lawsky
and Schakowsky,
uh,
of the,
of 1917 which all returned to,
but for the most part,
uh,
he stays away,
seems at least to stay away from the provocation and simply defends the right of
the formulas to exist and the integrity of what they're doing and the obvious
enemies.
And of course this is,
I can bombs language,
so on needing wince away from using it,
the obvious enemies in this case,
our figures like,
uh,
[inaudible] who,
the academician who,
um,
in a way defended the premises of the symbolists,
the other very lively group of antagonists to the formalists,
uh,
to the effect that,
poetry is all about imagery that it's all about,
uh,
that it's all about patterns of thought in the case of the symbolists thought
arising from the unconscious and being reinforced by sound by language.
So that language is subsidiary to imagery and thought,
uh,
kind of handmaiden of it,
the vessel.
In other words into which,
uh,
the energies of symbolic thought are poured.
Um,
and it's this basic antagonism,
this difference of opinion that I can bomb,
wants to focus on,
uh,
and indeed does focus on,
but at the same time there is a feeling somehow there is a feeling and it's
very,
it's very clear in an essay by Jaco Edison called the generation that squandered
it's poets.
Uh,
there's a feeling of a kind,
something like bureaucratization is taking hold.
Something like the,
or an atmosphere in which our perceptions of the things around us become
automated.
Schlocky in particular is very much preoccupied with the sense of the
automization automat as ization or autonomism.
I much prefer the latter word of perception.
The way in which we no longer really see what's around us.
I quoted the other day while a saying that poetry should make the visible a
little hard to see.
By the same token,
she Klowski insists and his colleagues insist that the business of the
roughening of surface by means of various modes of literariness is two d
familiarize automated perceptions to make us suddenly see again,
see the nature of the language that we're using.
And indeed also to see,
and this is very clear by the way,
uh,
in the essay literature as technique and your anthology that I,
that I recommended that you read,
but also at the same time to see the world itself anew by means of devices of
language that tear the film away from our eyes.
Uh,
and so the familiarization against the backdrop of a kind of gray uniformity
that Yaka person in his essay on the generation that squandered it's poets
called bit byt.
I don't know how to pronounce that.
I don't know a word of Russian.
And so I actually try to avoid using the rather well known Russian equivalents
for these terms because I feel like an idiot,
you know,
I mean,
I,
yes,
I see them in the tax just as anybody else does.
But since I don't really know what I mean,
except by means of the translation,
why should I use them?
But in any case,
this is a well known term used by [inaudible] in this essay,
which,
uh,
is like all such terms that that somehow wander into other languages,
is difficult to translate.
That's why they wander into other languages,
but it means something like a kind of dulled grayness or ordinariness of life.
And it's against that backdrop.
It's that sense of bureaucratized existence that defamiliarization has to a
certain extent the ideological purpose of dispelling and undermining.
Uh,
one has to recognize,
in other words,
that this motive,
that the,
that this motive force stands behind,
uh,
the work of the Russian formalists uh,
so that the claim,
uh,
to be strictly scientific,
you know,
needs to be hedged a little bit as a return of the aesthetic or return of value,
uh,
understood as the insistence that life doesn't need to be all that dull.
That really is implicit in the Russian formalists viewpoint.
Literariness then what is literariness?
It is those aspects of a text,
the way in which those devices have a text that called themselves to our
attention are new.
That is to say the way in which they shake up perception in the fat,
in the fact that we're not used to seeing.
And,
and,
and in a way this call for that which is new is worldwide.
At the same time you have Ezra pound among the high modernist and the West
saying make it new as his slogan.
Uh,
you have the various uh,
observations of Elliot and Joyous and others that I cited last time and talking
about the background to the new criticism,
all of them insisting on the necessity of difficulty,
of novelty,
of coming to terms with the immediacy of one's particular circumstances.
Uh,
getting away from that,
which is familiar and ordinary and vague.
It is a eight,
eight,
eight is a transnational idea and other words,
which nevertheless has obviously certain specific applications depending on
where it is.
The newness that the Russian formalists are interested in is not just any
newness.
It has to do particularly with the palpable or roughened form of that which de
familiarizes.
Now how do we understand this form form as opposed to what?
This is a crucial issue for the Russian formalists which they handle very
boldly.
Part of their platform is that everything is form.
There is no distinction,
in other words,
between form and content.
That's the fundamental mistake as they see it,
that they're enemies,
uh,
of various kinds make in their understanding,
in their approach to literature,
but you know,
their own basic distinctions are dualistic,
aren't they?
The distinction between poetic and practical language,
the distinction between plot and story that is thanks in between rhythm and
meter and all of these cases.
You know,
you're tempted to say,
well Gee,
one of those must be four and the other must be content in particular.
Obviously plot and story where we're plot as the constructiveness of the text
and the story is what the text is about.
Doesn't that sound a lot like form and content?
Well,
I actually think the Russian farmer list can be defended against the charge that
unbeknownst to themselves,
they fall back into forum content distinctions by a siding.
But by,
by insisting on this variety of dualities,
uh,
now I want to spend a little time,
suggesting developing the way in which that defense could be,
could be undertaken.
[inaudible] can practical language.
You've already been hearing this and I a Richards and in the new critics and
they in a way do while the new critics and the in a variety of ways insists that
form has meaning for them is content and so on.
There's still not really breaking the distinction between form and content.
And there's an obvious sense in which they understand poetic language to be that
in which form is predominate and predominant and practical language to be that
in which content is dominant.
But the Russian formalists see it in a slightly different way.
Content is a function
or,
or let me say,
practical language,
they purpose,
in other words of communicating facts of communicating at all,
which we associate with practical language is a function of poetic language.
That is to say it coexists with poetic language.
It is an aspect of a text,
the way in which it does communicate.
In other words,
which has to an which has to be understood as existing in a dynamic functional
relationship with those aspects of the text in which literariness is dominant.
It's not a question.
In other words of of poetry or of a novel being some Har on other strictly a
matter of poetic language in poetry or the novel.
You can argue that the poetic function,
and this is the term Yaka person will ultimately use for it in his essay,
linguistics and politics.
You can argue that the poetic function is the dominant,
but that's not to say that practical language is absent or that it doesn't have
its own function.
So,
and this by the way,
uh,
if,
if we begin by talking about poetic and practical language,
we're beginning where the Russian formalists began as I could,
as I can buy them explains in 1914,
uh,
the first publication of their journal was entirely devoted to poetic sound.
That is just to the way in which,
uh,
sound seems indeed is not just subservient to the elaboration of sense.
One of the things by the way,
the foremost that I can bomb does in passing is remind us that we should be on
our guard against thinking that sound is on amount of poetic.
That is,
that,
that it reflects,
uh,
the meaning of what it's talking about.
When,
uh,
when I say,
um,
pigeon,
I don't really seem to have any particular sense of an automotive poetic word,
but if I use the Latin Ppo,
all of a sudden I say,
oh,
that's onomatopoetic.
Well,
the formalist and also,
so sir,
this is one of the most important links between the Pharma list.
And so sir are very carefully on their guard against supposing that sound,
that the ways in which we hear language is odd amount of poetic because that
would suggest once again in keeping with symbolist ideas that sound was
subservient to meaning the importance of the first,
the earliest work or the Russian formalists was the establishment of the idea
that sound goes its own way and is not subservient to anything that it is.
It's that it is,
uh,
a device independent of though interacting with other devices,
and that it doesn't exist for the purpose of elucidating anything.
In fact,
it exists amazingly,
uh,
in order to hinder understanding in the kinds of texts that were inclined to
call poetic.
It's repetitive,
it's anti economical.
It's retardant
language of this source is a device.
And in relation to other devices,
it's called a function.
We call it a function.
That is to say it has a function.
It has a function within a,
at our understanding of the way in which a text has structure.
Every aspect of the structure of the text can be understood as having a
function.
The rain in Spain falls mainly on the plane.
Now this is an example of a text,
uh,
in which,
alliteration is plainly predominant.
It is a repetitive,
uh,
we understand it to be somehow different from the ordinary way in which a fact
is communicated but are,
but if we are not Russian formalists were attempted to say,
well,
you know,
it's a Nimo technic device,
uh,
introduced for the purpose,
for the purpose.
That is to say subservient to the communication of a fact.
By the way,
I've never known whether it is a fact,
but a lot of mountains or rainy by Pyrenees,
I suppose they're dry.
I really have no idea whether it's a fact,
but,
um,
uh,
and it's not important in my fair lady,
whether it's a fact.
What's important in my fair lady is to repeat the repetitiousness of verse.
The rain in Spain falls mainly on the plain in terms of the tautology of the
plot.
Eliza Doolittle tries repeatedly to say that,
but just like Nido and speedy failing or being unwilling to push Tony out of his
problem.
So Eliza repeatedly says the Rhine and spine files mine,
Leon,
the pipeline.
And that's not good enough.
And so the repetition in the plot reinforces the repetition of the sound in
question and whether or not it's a fact is completely immaterial to Eliza.
It's completely a material to Henry Higgins and it's completely immaterial to
the outcome of my fair lady.
Well,
that's important in my fair lady is the functionality of repetition in the
transformation of a principal character into a lady that is,
and,
and so in informal as terms,
that's the way we have to understand what if we weren't formalists we would
suppose,
as I say,
to be a nema technical device for the purpose of communicating something about
the weather in Spain.
All right.
And,
uh,
and,
and I think,
I think it's interesting to think in those terms about the relationship among
devices.
Now
the point is that,
yes,
and this,
and this is what emerged from subsequent thought in the Russian formalists
movement.
First,
first wave or phase had to do strictly with sound,
but then they began to say,
well,
what about this notion of device?
What about the way in which maybe the best thing to do if we're going to avoid
keeping once and again and again and again falling into the trap of making one
aspect of the texts subservient to other tax tech aspects merely there for the
purpose of of,
of reinforcing content.
If we're going to avoid doing this,
if we're going to see the text as a text that has a structure,
hadn't we better say that everything in it is form that everything in it is a
device.
How are we going to do that?
Because it would certainly seem that text refer to things.
Well,
yes they do.
So why don't we call that to which they refer for example,
in the case of socialist realism or indeed realism of any kind,
why don't we call that to which they refer the society function.
Why don't we say,
Oh yeah.
In a certain kind of text,
the dominant,
the dominant device in that text is referentiality is the way in which the real
world is hooked onto and that can be understood as a device.
With respect to other devices,
it becomes at certain moments in the evolution of forms or garden into the
Russian formalists the dominant,
you see this is the way in which you avoid the forum content distinction.
You say,
oh,
so called content.
What other people call content as a device like any other and it engages in the
struggle for dominance with all the other devices that one can identify as
aspects of literature take for take the distinction between plot and story.
I mean there you would really think before I'm a lister on sin eyes plot.
Yes,
we all agree that's the constructiveness of the story.
That's the way the story is put together,
how the overcoat has made and so on.
But story,
that's what the plot is about.
And if that's what the plot is about,
how can we avoid calling it content?
Well,
it's very interesting in the first place notice that sometimes story can be the
dominant in obviously formal terms.
I think of that story that all of you are probably right in school.
The things they carried by Tim O'brien.
Uh,
it's about,
it's a list of the contents of a,
of the knapsack of a soldier during the Vietnam War.
Just a list of the contents and of course all these items and then APSAC are
evocative.
And what they do is they suggest a plot by the end of the story.
In other words,
there is implied a plot.
It's just the opposite of the usual relationship between plot and story or a
narrowly a plot construct.
Something which is implied.
That is to say that which happens that which we can talk about in paraphrase or
as something as,
as a subject matter outside the text.
But here in O'brien story,
you're given the subject matter and the subject matter itself becomes the
dominant device and it implies in your imagination a way to construct it.
But the way to construct it is not the dominant,
the way to construct it as something that's up to you.
What's the dominant in the text is just the stuff,
the stuff in his knapsack listed with as little implication as possible.
And so that's an instance of the way in which you can see the relationship
between plot and story as a relationship of devices,
even though it's awfully tempting to say,
oh,
the stories,
just the content and the plots the form.
But no,
the formulas don't want to keep that distinction.
For the reasons that I've been,
that I've been trying to develop.
Any device can be the dominant at a given moment in the development of literary
history.
Any device can be the dominant in Hiawatha.
Longfellows Hiawatha meter is the device,
Dah,
Dah.
You know how it goes in,
in well in Tennyson sound as the device.
Uh,
you know,
the sort of Burma is haunt the,
Oh,
I have no memory at all today.
The,
uh,
the uh,
I'm mixing it up with a line of Cates and I'm going to say something else about
Keith.
So I'll just tell you that seller thought the two most beautiful words in the
English language where cellar door,
uh,
and that,
um,
that was his preoccupation in the making of poetry so that we can say that the
dominant device in Tennyson's poetry as in much Victoria in poetry,
certainly Swinburne's,
uh,
is sound.
And in Keets we can say that the dominant devices imagery,
his,
his famous emphasis on synesthesia and the way in which the various senses merge
in the evocation of images.
Uh,
in other words,
uh,
of course the,
um,
the academicians and the symbolist,
we're obsessed with imagery.
That's not to say that a Russian formalists can't deal with imagery in a certain
poet.
The image,
the,
the image patterns can certainly be recognized as the dominant device.
That would probably be the case.
For example,
with Keats and Gertrude Stein,
the dominant is repetition,
undoubtedly,
uh,
the,
and,
and in,
in Wordsworth or Joyce or wolf,
uh,
the dominant is perhaps not formal.
Think of words.
Think of the,
the feeling of that Wordsworth blank verse just kind of disappears into pros.
I don't think that's quite true.
Uh,
but there's a general feeling that as Matthew Arnold said,
Wordsworth has no style and Wordsworth or Joyce or wolf,
the dominant is the interiority of consciousness.
That is the,
the,
the way in which the way in which,
uh,
what,
what we call a stream of consciousness or the inwardness of thought,
uh,
motivates.
This is another word that you encounter.
And I can,
Bob's essay motivates everything that everything else that goes on in the text.
In other words,
it an enormous variety of aspects of literature understood as literariness can
become the dominant.
Now,
as soon as we start talking about things like the dominant,
uh,
we are also aware of the evanescence of dominance.
What is a culinary in one generation?
And here I'm alluding to a passage quoted by I can bomb what's culinary.
And One generation,
for example,
the devices of crime fiction in the work of Dostoyevsky become absolutely
central.
He's thinking primarily of grime and punished punishment.
But this is true of other works of dust,
dust,
Asca as well.
Um,
so that the,
the,
the devices of the dime detective novel actually then become the motivating
dominant of the,
of a mainstream literary form,
but then they in turn run their course and are replaced by some other dominant,
in other words,
once you start thinking about the evanescence of dominance,
you're also thinking about literary history.
One of the,
the most false charge and it was a charge leveled by Trotsky among many others
against the Russian formalists is that they ignore history.
The same charge,
uh,
so often leveled against the new critics.
They don't at all ignore history almost from the beginning,
but increasingly during the 20s,
uh,
they turned their attention to the problems of literary historiography and they
said some rather bracing things about it.
Uh,
on your,
uh,
in your text on page Oh 12,
the left hand column,
I'll keep referring to those stamped numbers,
uh,
left hand side of your text.
We find a,
I can bomb a evoking and exchange of opinion between the ethnographic critic
vessel Lawsky and Victor Slawsky Schlocky.
He said third of the way down had encountered vessel oskies formula,
a formula broadly based on the ethnographic principle that the purpose of new
form is to express new content,
new content.
In other words being those social and historical and environmental forces that
oblige literary techniques to change.
That's the ethnographic position.
It is.
That's the word used.
It is obviously also the materialist or social position.
History produces literature and not just literary history but social history
produces literature.
Philosophy disagreed and and he decided to advance a completely different point
of view.
The work of art arises from a background of other works and through association
with them.
The form of a work of art is defined by its relation to other works of art
deforms existing prior to it.
Not only parody.
Parody by the way is uh,
a very,
very broad term in Russian formulas.
Thought in a way simply meaning change.
That is to say the way in which one text inevitably riffs on another text in
elaborating its own devices and emphases.
Ah,
and in search of a new kind of dominance,
uh,
not only parody,
but also any kind of work of art is created parallel to an opposed to some kind
of form.
The purpose of new form is not to express new content,
but to change and old form,
which has lost its aesthetic quality.
That is to say lost its power to de Familia eyes lost its power to take the film
away from our eyes.
Now this,
um,
it really,
I mean as you think about it,
it's 80 herself.
You know,
that's all very bracing and daring,
but vessel oss,
caves,
right?
We,
we,
we know literature is produced by historical forces.
What does it mean?
You know,
a new form comes about only to replace an old form,
which has ceased to be aesthetically viable.
How does that happen?
You know,
the old phone,
it's,
you know,
you've got to appeal the social forces.
If you're going to talk about change.
That really does seem to me to be the spontaneous conclusion we want to draw.
That's why I gave you the extraordinary passage on your sheet,
uh,
for the end of 10 neon offs on literary evolution written also 1927 written also
and other words in response to Trotsky's literature and revolution.
This is what 10 Yanno says in formalist historiography.
The prime significance of major social factors is not at all discarded and other
ones where we're,
where we're not just playing a game here.
We to understand the relevance of what we call the society function.
Rather,
it must be elucidated in its full extent through the problem of the evolution of
literature.
This is in contrast to the establishment of the direct influence of major social
factors and this is the amazing part of this audience which I think is remarked
truly remarkable,
which the major social effect,
the influence of major social impact,
which replaces the study of evolution of literature with the study of the
modification of literary works.
That is to say there deformation,
you see the distinction in natural selection,
certain things happen.
There is mutation.
New genes emerge as dominant,
no longer recessive or Leighton and organisms change.
That's evolution.
But organisms change against a backdrop,
you know,
organisms changing like crazy in comes the prehensile thumb.
And then next thing you know,
you've got a colossal earthquake and the possessor of the prehensile thumb
disappears from the earth,
which is to say very possibly the human spaces will never develop.
That's the modification
of a form.
And it strikes me that that's a remarkable distinction you will get in any
period spontaneously.
The sorts of impulses that bring about a socialist realism.
But if you have a UK is from above telling you that if you're going to write,
it has to be socialist realism.
That's a modification.
That is the modification of what,
of what would and does evolve in and of itself within an understanding of
literary historiography.
The distinction,
it seems to me compelling.
They all,
my objection to be made to it perhaps indeed is that much of the time it's just
more trouble than it's worth to enforce it.
I mean,
it is,
it,
it would drive us into such baroque circumlocutions,
uh,
and avoidances of the obvious to say,
oh,
social factors have nothing to do with this,
uh,
that we might as well just sort of not give the distinction up because I think
it's very important always to have it in the back of our minds.
It's important in Darwinian terms to have it in the back of our minds.
And that's what,
that's what a [inaudible] is insisting on.
That's why he calls his essay on literary evolution,
not literary revolution,
but literary evolution.
Uh,
and I think it's terribly important to keep the distinction in the back of our
minds,
even if we find it in practical terms well nigh impossible,
possibly even in many contexts,
a waste of time to be perpetually and forcing it.
Uh,
it is nevertheless a distinction that does exist once you think about it that
deserves to exist and deserves to be remembered.
When we think about the variety of ways in which literary history can be
written.
Now I'm going to stop their time's up.
Uh,
there's a little more to say,
I think,
uh,
and certainly the possible ways in which Russian formalism is subject to
critique a knit need quickly to be passed and review.
Uh,
we'll do all this next time before we get into,
so,
sir.